before we say goodbye we want to play a
quick round up truth or dare
and playing today we have krista
avenpotto hi krista hi it's so nice to
meet you
i just have to say you are just
radiating beauty and good energy oh my
god that means so much to me because you
are one of my beauty icons so i and ross
as well i just love the show so much and
i have to say that this show i start
every day with the show i have watched
since the premiere yes
part of my life and i just love it so
much it's like my bright joyful spot
thank you
thank you well
are we gonna do a truth or a dare we're
gonna do a dare all right we're down to
do just about anything so what is it so
the dare is
will you show me your purse uh-huh and
the one thing that you never leave home
without
um do we have my purse which ironically
okay this is her purse look at this look
at
that that is a new york purse hilarious
okay
okay let's see um this is it i
mean this is as honest as it gets
okay see what do i have in here
oh i mean hello
nothing to see here that's cute
um i have a hat
[Applause]
and i just thought i don't know maybe i
was gonna go out later what
[Laughter]
um
let's see your bag is just as organized
as your desk always a game for always a
game for the kids
oh it's a good idea i'll tell you the
thing well first of all just let's see
what do i have
i mean
[Applause]
whoa
true i'll tell you i think the thing
that means the most to me
is the week magazine and i have an
erasable pen
because i love doing the crossword every
week
i love it cute
so
but i'll go with i never leave home
without an erasable pen because the
pencil is too light i can't see it
and i'm too afraid of real ink because i
make a lot of mistakes and have to go
back and rework
and uh so yeah that's the inside of my
purse
wow that's like all the inside of your
purse
oh brave
all right see i told you we'd do just
about anything right ross well what do
you never leave home without um drew's
purse
i can fit you inside of it you know what
i always bring with me i always have my
chopstick and my breast spray always
right here this is like i'm panicking i
don't have this this is everything about
our two miniature necessities for you
and just a complete s show for me
this is me this is her but guess what if
you got stuck on a deserted island who
you hanging out with this one for sure
thank you krista thank you thank you so
much for choosing to spend your time
with us we make this show for you so
take it with you
[Music]
you